all right cbs news has noticed that kids
today are fat
and uh i think we've all probably noted
that
and they've found the culprit
it's not what you think
or maybe it is if you think just like
these people
god pity you uh let's listen
there's a new study showing how climate
change specifically higher temperatures
is making our children uh more inactive
and more obese the study published in a
journal temperature found today's
children are 30 less aerobically fit
than their parents were at their age
fewer children are reaching the world
health organization's recommendation of
60 minutes of exercise a day now listen
it has been a lot harder hotter and the
weather has been crazy but i think it
also has to do with technology you know
yeah
it's one thing not to go outside but
these kids don't go outside because they
can stay inside and be on their phones
play video games and be social without
having to go outside and be social
okay well it's not a lot hotter first of
all according to the government's own
climate change website climate.gov you
can go there
temperatures have risen two degrees
fahrenheit
since pre-industrial times
so that's if we're going with their data
and we're just going to accept it on
face value
then two degrees
in 150
years
according to this information we're
about a half a degree hotter maybe
than we were when i was a kid in the 90s
and this counts as a lot hotter
it explains why kids don't go outside
turn the temperature down by half a
degree and it changes or turn it up
rather by having and it changes
everything
really but but what about the seasons
so every time these people talk about
climate change they just ignore the
concept of seasons
i mean the temperature does drop by a
lot more than half a degree for kids
today
because it's not summer temperatures all
year long unless you live on the equator
so do kids suddenly go outside and play
in the fall in the spring
in the in the winter in the early summer
no they don't
also by the way you can look at obesity
rates by state
and there is no correlation between
average temperature and obesity west
virginia is one of the fattest states
with a but it's got a mean annual
temperature of 56 degrees west virginia
but it's a beautiful
the the temperature is at least by my
for my taste the temperature is always
almost always great it's a beautiful
place a beautiful state to to go and run
around outside and yet
it's it's the second fattest state in
the country
florida is on average 20 degrees or more
hotter and yet it's one of the skinniest
states
and this becomes um
even more you know this lack of
correlation becomes even more apparent
when you look at it on a global scale
okay because there are a great many very
hot
um tropical
you know climates
where people are not only not obese but
oftentimes famished starving
you know their ribs are poking out of
their bodies
and why is that well because this is
about food
okay obesity is about food it's about
the foods you put in your body
it's how many how much how many calories
you put in your body
versus how many you burn
that's where obesity comes from that's
it
that is the whole story of obesity
if you are obese it is because
you are
taking in a lot more calories than
you're burning
end of discussion
regardless of what the administration
defines as a recession americans are
certainly worried food and gas prices
are higher than i've ever seen them in
my lifetime which is why i'm so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers a
recession-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe imagine if car companies did
this like what if you could have bought
your 2020 ford at 1990s pricing that's
what good ranchers does for its
customers not only that but good
ranchers is also currently running a
back to school give back program with
the goal of donating 100 000 high
quality meals this month to children in
need so go to goodranchers.com walsh use
codewall should check out they'll get 30
off plus free shipping you can um
subscribe to lock in your price and
recession proof your meals for life and
you can help these guys reach their goal
of donating 100 000 meals to children
who may need it going into the fall
semester that's goodranchers.com
walsh and use codewalsh at checkout and
that's why in third world countries
um they don't seem to have the fat gene
surprisingly
why is that because they're not eating
enough
and if you don't eat enough then instead
of being overweight you're going to be
very much underweight
so why are kids fat
i mean it is an important question
it is something we should be talking
about
but they're fat because they're eating
garbage food
and they're sitting around on their
phones all day
we hear the cbs guy at the end he makes
mention of that well i think it has
something to do with technology too
that's not just something to do with
technology
that's the whole that that along with
with the food that's that's that's the
whole story 50 to 50 right there
the food is bad
and kids are sitting around on their
phones all day
doesn't matter how beautiful the
temperature is outside
and it's even worse like it's
yeah this is this is being we've gone
way beyond mere laziness or anything
like that kids many kids today
no longer have
just the innate desire
to go run around outside
okay and that should be innate
now i know for my own kids we don't give
them phones we don't do technology um we
don't they we have a tv we don't let
them watch it that much though
and and my kids can certainly be lazy
don't get me wrong about that
but they still have this youthful
natural energy where they just
they want to be outside i mean i i hear
all that well it's too hot for kids to
go outside we live in tennessee
it's like 6 000 degrees here all the
time with a humidity of 6 000
and my kids will go run around outside
we have to tell them to come in so they
don't get heat exhaustion
and that's normal for kids
that doesn't make my kids special quite
the opposite just makes them normal kids
but for a lot of kids they they they've
become so numb so sort of dead to the
world
that they don't even have the desire to
run outside and explore
and go into the woods and just whatever
kids do you know we we all tell the
stories about when we were kids and
you'd go out and you know you go out at
seven o'clock in the morning you'd come
back you wouldn't be back until dinner
well that's not just a get off my lawn
you know back in my day kind of
rant it is an observation
about a wide sweeping social change that
has happened in this culture and it is a
it is a
a horrible change
and we we still
really cannot
conceive of what this is going to be
like in the future
to have a generation of kids raised on
this stuff raised on screens utterly
dependent on them
from
toddler on
um what does that look like
what kind of world are we living in in
40 years 50 years i mean certainly it's
going to be a fat world even fatter than
it is now
but in a lot of ways that's like the
least of our problems
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated